A Friendly Reminder to All Foundation Staff
- Dr. Bright is NOT: A superhero of any sort,
Head of Public Relations, in charge of Orientation
for new staff, a doctor of psychology, a member
of Site Command, made out of bacon, in possession
of an IQ over 300, Head of SCP Review, or
a member of Maintenance Staff - Sorry boys,
Dr. Bright IS a member of Site Command.
It's usually best not to ask why.
It's O5 Command you're thinking of.
Given that he’s constantly taking other
people’s bodies to propagate himself, it’s
no surprise that Dr. Bright might be a little
prone to the occasional identity crisis.
This is, however, no excuse for him to confuse
others - though especially new recruits - by
claiming to have seemingly every title under
the sun except his own.
Possessing the body of a doctor of psychology
does not mean the title passes to you, Dr.
Bright.
This isn’t Highlander.